hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay
hopefully the volume is all under
control now I'm recording it separately
from my audio how's that
oh hello magazines enter flame mint
weekly alright whatever
that amanda Bynes looks like yeah
no no whatever what the hell all these
doors are locked
huh well what the hell
I'm here now this is where I came from
maybe I'm looking for a key of some sort
that's what I imagine is gonna happen
that and some terrifying things okay
what's all this then
I think in here that I needed nope
okay mmm I'll wait what's this dear
Jenny dear Yanni tor
I have a problem with some lights could
you please turn off the electricity for
a short while so I can fix it okay all
right maybe there's a way to turn off
the electricity but I can't get in
anywhere back what a hacky hat who
knocked over this plant hmm going on ah
lost again lost Ivan I don't even have
an inventory so hmm
could it have been back the way I came
maybe I needed to do something before
this game is not obvious not not obvious
okay oh hello
I hear electricity but that's from the
thingy uh-huh no ha ha boom yeah yeah
this I saw spark
yeah did get some no hmm I do see sparks
coming from it no probably not though
mmm-hmm and there was a stupid map with
no directions on it
gotta be something to do with that thing
because it is barking it's not like I
can use it or anything the flashlight at
no no okay all right that a journal J no
absolutely not
huh yeah go back through hey you through
here
oh man Vivian and Mel
absolutely not oh that's right there I'm
an idiot
I'm an idiot it's right there that'd do
it
yep there we go okay marlis closed aha
and here no oops I was wrong okay
nope
nope yep nope
let me through all right Oh why's this
boarded up hmm huh got an answer to that
question oh oh this is up here
ah it all comes together a gun and a
battery give you some her get some as
some hip cool young uns would say no
piano long homo nope
it's jammed I like this okay
oh-oh-oh-oh
turning off power was the worst idea
ever
oh-oh-oh-oh headshot headshot head she's
jumping all over the place
oh my god Oh get some no die here we go
okay oh my god I'm down to 40 health
already what's up Ricky Bob
no I'm leaving I'm leaving I'm leaving
I'm leaving I don't have time oh oh I'm
gonna run that battery ah maybe 300 why
did I come through push a button
oh I know what that was
oh I know where that was what what huh
huh okay I know where that was those
back um before in the in the first area
I fir I don't know the name of it so
whatever but I can get back this way
[ __ ]
nope ah got here oh my god it hit me so
hard ah I don't hit me don't hit me
don't hit me bro don't hit me no no no
no are you no no no no kill me don't
kill me bro
don't kill me it was in here it was in
here who's in here who's in here oh my
god ah here we go here we go yes I made
it I made it uh wha what that's my heart
what did uh how'd that happen
did I not have enough health to survive
this fall I took what okay or this isn't
lead anywhere
this is a trick
ah ah
maybe that guy's after me I don't know I
don't know what the deal is
Oh Oh what is the deal it's uh I got I
don't I don't know I don't know but
there's some guy after me there's some
guy after me it's some dude - dude -
dude dude pills can I get those pills
please please pills
I see pills please there we go okay now
maybe oh no no no I can't see I can't
see I can't see anything
easy listen listen listen aah oh my god
I'm flying blind
ah I fell into the hole okay straight to
hit no batteries no batteries left
no oh batteries oh damn it what's going
on oh my goodness I'm going into the
bathroom again because there were more
pills in there I remember I need to take
these pills
ah Oh jump up here you can't get me it's
up I I'm swinging a mite I can't see
anything it's so there's one in here
with me I can't find the pills light
please thank you no no no no no oh come
on why was I on the floor oh okay
straight to the bathroom and then don't
run out of flashlights
Lisak okay okay get the pills get the
bill okay I got the pills no swing not
moving up there we go
aha got you know and Binga yeah that's
what I thought okay so I'm in the
bathroom
in complete darkness I don't like this
flashlight mechanic because it runs out
way too quick and there's like no other
light okay
so let's evaluate of now that I can take
a moment to pause and think and let my
batteries to charge okay so it opened
the great to that area I know it did
that but when I went in there it was
like it I fell and then it just I think
it's just a death pit because I don't
think it went anywhere so where else
could I go in complete darkness where I
wouldn't die
let me first well I still got some
flashlights let me try going back to
that area
ah okay and let me see if I can survive
it now that I got 50 Hills
nope it's insta-kill it's just bad news
so why did it open what in the world
reason did it open for so confused oh
okay whatever I need to go somewhere
else then somewhere with actual lighting
but that place is probably few oh I
opened the door with Mindy
ah-ha
yup yup on the table on the table there
you can't get me from here haha what
losers bless a can i getcha Ya Derry up
Oh so pro Oh leet skills
hahaha you're dead one down come here
come at me bro
hahaha oh that is creepy come on come on
Terry
ah
come on there we go are we ah yeah yeah
no no there we go
gotcha come on take your lumps there we
go okay huh all right so anyway the
battery recharges up to I think a
maximum of five there was another place
that was that I opened in here and here
but this led nowhere it was entirely
useless and just wasting my batteries
what was the point of coming back here
if if that if I push that button and it
opened it open that door thank you oh
that doesn't sound good it did all that
for a reason right
i recharge my flashlight before I go
anywhere maybe he's like bugged and as I
was going down the ladder was supposed
to do a level transition there but
something got screwed up and it didn't
go
because why else would you open that
place I may have a bug game may have a
bug game I'm not sure come on battery
there we go okay I think you can get up
to three but time to wait oh hello
come here friend ah no no table table
table table girl the table damn it table
there we go okay okay one more down take
care of you nope miss me there you go
okay another one bites distt now we
going here oh what's it here oh never
mind never mind
I was stupid was there something in here
I did kind of go through here kind of
quickly running away from people I don't
think there was I'm gonna run out of
flashlight kind of turn back on the
power please please power on nope and
I'm in complete darkness again fantastic
well this is unfortunate not sure I'm in
love with his mechanics okay can't turn
the power back on that's for sure whoa
whoa okay
so that's a no-go it has to be something
with that great that I opened it just
has to be I mean there would have been
no other reason for it to open other
than to let me go on my merry way right
right
not here some light here a monsters I am
Not Afraid of monsters
what oops I think it's reloaded a
quicksave oh yeah
they put quicksave is x6 and quick load
is f7 okay wait wait I'm out of time for
this episode I'm a little puzzled maybe
I might try to fiddle around and try to
figure out what's going on before I
start the next episode so I'm not
completely stuck but anyway thank you
guys so much for watching hope you're
enjoying it and as always I will see you
in the next part bye bye